riesige schwarze löcher stellen forscher
vorräte fünf außergewöhnliche blase wenn
den weg worden
wir gehen ihrem geheimnis auf die spur
jetzt bei klick von 20 fiction herzig
gekommen ein blasser was so viel
bedeutet wie blazing quasi steller
objekt zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass
auf ihm eine hohe emissionen anstrahlung
hervorgeht die nasa wenn sie auch
blackrock howard galaxie zu finden wenn
diese galaxien durch hoch energiereiche
setzt sie mit nahezu
lichtgeschwindigkeit auf ihrem zentrum
rat jetzt entstehen wenn materie in das
zentrum eines schwarzen loches wird also
auch in das zentrum einer galaxie die
strahlung der jets können wir hier auf
der erde sein registrieren und
analysieren durch blasen konnten wir
schon vieles lernen und unsere
erkenntnis grenzen erneut deutlich
ausweiten zum beispiel konnte die
herkunft der geister teilchen also der
neutrinos geklärt werden
das 2005 entdeckte neutrino big board
stammte von einem blatt war er bei dem
strahlungsausbruch der galaxie pkf b 14
44 18 entstanden ist der stallung
ausbruch habe sich nämlich zur selben
zeit und am selben ort wie die
entstehung des neutrinos ereignet und
würde damit die neutrino quelle darf
deren forscher berechneten eine gerade
mal 5 prozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit
dass diese beiden ereignisse zufällig
vonstatten gingen im umkehrschluss
stammte das neutrino mit 95 prozentiger
wahrscheinlichkeit auf diesen
strahlungsausbruch jetzt verblüffen
erneut sehr geheimnisvolle glaser
genauer gesagt deren motoren also die
schwarzen löcher im zentrum der galaxien
die forscher der nasa die mit dem
vermittler area telescope lat
aufgespürten gleich jahre würden auf den
kindertagen unseres universums stammt
die sind zwischen 1,4 und 1,9 milliarden
jahre nach dem urknall entstanden und
das ist dabei aber nicht das einzig
besondere an den objekten die blase
wänden eine für ihr alter extrem starkes
planung aus angetrieben werden wie
jeweils durch ein massereiches schwarzes
loch im zentrum zwei dieser schwarzen
löcher bewirten sogar eine macke vermerk
einer milliarde sonnen damit haben
fast in die top 50 der größten bisher
entdeckten schwarzen löcher geschafft
darüber gasparini von italiens better
aging science center in rom zufolge ist
eine der wichtigsten fragen die wie
solch gigantischen schwarzen löcher in
so jungen jahren also so kurz nach dem
urknall entstehen kommt man habe nämlich
aktuell noch keinerlei erkenntnisse über
die mechanismen dieses rapiden wachstums
übrigen wenn wir hier von einer extrem
starken strahlung sprechen dann bewegen
wir uns in der strahl größenordnung von
2 billionen sonnen das ist wirklich
wahnsinnig wieder aber ist die
wissenschaft an die grenzen des
universums gestoßen hat die erkenntnis
grenzen ausgeweitet und nun ist die
sogar die neuen forschungsarbeiten die
grenzen auszuweiten projektleiter marco
borriello von der kämpfen university in
south carolina bezeichnete den fuß sogar
nur als spitze eines eisbergs was kommt
denn noch alles auf uns zu ich würde mal
sagen wir haben die schwarzen löcher
bisher vollkommen als rand erscheinung
und sonderfall unterschätzt in den
kommenden wochen werde ich mich öfter
mit dem thema beschäftigen und
interessante und verblüffende theorien
vorstellen die unser weltbild
wahrscheinlich auf den kopf stellen
werden weit gespannt hier übrigens
draufklicken wenn ihr mehr über schwarze
löcher erfahren wollt da sind alle
unsere bisherigen videos gesammelt und
wenn er in der zukunft nicht zum thema
verpassen wollte drückt mir hier ein abo
aufs auge und gegner noch einen auf die
glocke und ansonsten bis dann